hace un año y medio el periodista
francés olivier uva fue secuestrado en
mali por él jn y emme un grupo
extremista vinculado a al-qaeda
el periodista freelance secuestrado el 8
de abril de 2021 había estado informando
para varios medios de comunicación en
mali y francia sus familiares no han
tenido noticias de él pero tuvo ha sido
visto en vídeos de propaganda difundidos
por sus captores su familia pide a los
franceses que envíen una petición al
elíseo exigiendo la liberación de dubai
usted dibuja mi hermano muere un poco
más día a día en el desierto olivier
permanece en nuestra mente a diario cada
hora cada minuto y según dos
personalidades públicas e incluso
antiguos rehenes se han pronunciado
pidiendo la liberación de olivia
el gobierno francés dice estar
plenamente comprometido con la
liberación del periodista incluso
después de que su fuerza abarcan se
retirará de malí el 15 de agosto la
discreción en condición es a la
discreción es un elemento esencial para
cualquier acción que el estado lleve a
cabo en zonas que son peligrosas y
delicadas sabemos que hay negociaciones
en curso y esperamos que estas
conversaciones discretas desemboquen en
la libertad de libia
racionalista el sábado olimpia celebró
su cumpleaños número 48 en cautiverio